each Tuesday our eye on money series
looks at financial issues affecting
Americans well this morning we are
focusing on an unprecedented agreement
by the credit monitoring agency Equifax
it will pay up to seven hundred million
dollars after a huge data breach in 2017
up to four hundred and twenty five
million dollars of that would establish
a fund to compensate consumers about one
hundred and forty seven million people
that's nearly half the country's
population had their personal and
financial information exposed Equifax
admits no wrongdoing and a federal court
still needs to sign off on the
settlement so to find out if you are
eligible for a payout we are joined by
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger always great to see you good
to see you good morning so this
settlement if it's approved by the
courts who will be eligible
so again of those 147 million people
some of them don't even know they were
impacted way back when almost two years
ago when the breach occurred you were
encouraged to go online to see hey is
your information compromised a lot of
people did it but many people didn't
Equifax followed up they mailed notices
you were impacted a lot of people blew
it off and so what we really are wanting
to do here is encourage people to stay
on top of this story go to ftc.gov slash
Equifax because there will be a tool
available that will let you know whether
you are impacted by this credit breach
I'm always amazed when there are
settlements like this just how much
money companies have sitting around like
oh 700 million yeah but so if people do
not come forward and stay on top of it
as you say does that mean Equifax will
keep the money well it's up to this 700
million dollars depending on how many
people jump into the pool but there's
really interesting details about what
you could be entitled to so free credit
monitoring for up to say ten years
whether it's through other credit
monitoring companies or Equifax
there's also a restoration of your
identity so that is a really important
component so that means if your identity
was compromised people they will help
you get things back on track I think the
one getting the most attention up to
$20,000 if you can prove that this
Equifax breach
actually damage you so that could be
including maybe time spent maybe it's
your identity was used to do something
else and so that $20,000 per person is
getting a lot of attention right now
people are rechecking their records yeah
how is this affected their business well
it's interesting because when Equifax
first announced this the stock price
tumbled it has since come back you
mentioned that they have 700 million
dollars sitting around they had already
put six hundred ninety million dollars
set aside but here's the critical
portion of this part of the question
nothing in the credit monitoring and
reporting businesses has substantively
changed and I think consumer advocates
are upset about meaning your data is
still or could be potentially
compromised that's exactly right that
they want them to beef these systems up
but I'm not sure that they really have
and so as consumers what does that mean
it means we have to be vigilant and that
means you keep an eye on that how
difficult would it be to prove that I
was breached I'm sitting at home looking
at you right now I think it is basically
very difficult to understand whether or
not that breach let's assume you were
breach whether it was used for nefarious
reasons and this is why that $20,000 is
going to be elusive I don't think a lot
of people are gonna be able to prove
that they were actually damaged
financially and that would be the case
we're gonna stay on this I promise FTC
gov Equifax sign up for the free email
alerts all right thank you got a lot
done
[Laughter]